Hello, everyone.
Welcome to CIFAR's Virtual Talk
in our series "Science is the Exit Strategy."
For those of you who may be new to CIFAR,
we are a global research
organization based in Canada.
We convene extraordinary minds
to address important questions
facing science and humanity.
I'm Rebecca Finlay,
and it is my pleasure to
be hosting today's talk
on governance, tech, and the pandemic,
and to explore the questions,
what do the debates on
contact tracing apps
in Canada and the U.K. tell us
about the broader policy
and governance questions
related to AI, tech, data,
and novel technologies,
and how can policy makers navigate
these questions effectively?
And to do so, I'm really delighted
to welcome Michael Geist and Carly Kind.
Michael is a law professor
at the University of Ottawa,
where he holds the Canada Research Chair
in Internet and E-Commerce Law.
He is the editor of several
technology law publications
and an internationally
syndicated columnist
on technology and the law,
the author of a popular blog
on internet and intellectual property law,
and the host of his own
podcast "Law Bytes,"
of which I should say I
am a loyal subscriber,
and I hardly urge people to listen in.
He has received numerous
international awards for his work
and has been appointed
to the Order of Ontario.
Carly Kind is the director
of the Ada Lovelace Institute in the U.K.
It is an independent research
and deliberative body
with a mission to ensure data
and AI work for people and society.
A human rights lawyer
and leading authority
on the intersection of technology,
policy, and human rights,
Carly has advised industry, government,
and nonprofit organizations
on digital rights,
privacy, data protection,
and corporate accountability.
She's worked with the European Commission,
the Council of Europe
and many U.N. bodies.
The catalyst for today's discussion
with Carly and Michael is CIFAR has report
for Canada's chief science
advisor, Dr. Mona Nemer,
on society, technology,
and ethics in a pandemic.
We were fortunate to assemble
an impressive group of experts,
both here in Canada and internationally,
to provide advice to this report
over a very few busy weeks in April.
Chaired by Anne McLellan,
the group met virtually several times,
published a report for
the chief science advisor,
and laid out principles and
implementation guidelines
for contact tracing apps in Canada.
Michael was a member of
the expert advisory group
that we brought together
to author the report,
and Carly was a member
of the international expert roundtable
that provided advice to the report.
They have both been active
in the public debate
on technology and COVID,
and I'm really delighted
that they can join us today.
So we're going to get
started, but before we do,
two quick housekeeping notes.
First of all, language.
I just wanna say that I tend
to use contact tracing
apps interchangeably
with risk exposure and
proximity notice apps,
and many other names that
have been given to apps,
so I appreciate the difference.
I was looking today.
I think there's over 40 countries
that have announced their
intent to either launch an app
or have launched an app already.
So I just wanna apologize in advance
that I tend to use contact tracing,
but I appreciate that there are subtleties
and differences in the language,
and we can talk a little bit about that.
And then, secondly, I just wanna say
that today's session will
last up to 45 minutes.
If you have a question,
please submit it through the Q&A function
at the bottom of your screen.
Also, we will be
recording today's session,
so you will be able to download
it and share it next week.
So Michael and Carly,
it's really great to have you both here.
When we were chatting
a little bit last week,
I shared with you that I
had recently done a talk
with Sir Tim Besley, who's an economist
at the London School of
Economics and a CIFAR fellow.
And we were talking just about this,
this question of providing
policy advice to government,
so experts and scientists
outside of government.
How do you do it?
And he noted sort of
two general principles
in the work that he does.
First of all, that experts
can provide a framing
or a framework within which
policymakers can get a sense
of sort of the pros and the cons
and weigh the risks and benefits
of what are complex policy decisions
that they themselves will need to take.
And, secondly, that experts
can really sort of
provide a longterm view,
maybe sort of try to give a big picture
and a sense of the potential implications
of what might have to be a
rather hasty policy decision.
So we talked a little bit
about sort of framing the discussion
around contact tracing apps
and novel technologies in a pandemic,
sort of within that context
in terms of what we were
hoping to accomplish today,
so really sort of step back
and give some sense of the bigger picture,
take the longer-term view,
and what might be some policy questions
that emerge out of this
discussion that should be part
of a broader policy debate moving forward.
So to get started,
I think it would probably be useful
just to do some level setting
between what's happening in Canada
and what's happening in the U.K.
in terms of the launch
of contact tracing apps
and other health identity technologies
that are emerging during the pandemic.
Michael, can you sort
of cast your eyes back
to, I don't know, mid-March,
seems like a long time ago,
and give us a sense of where
things are today in Canada?
- Sure, I'd be happy to,
and thanks again for the
invitation to participate in this.
So, I mean, I think back in March,
we saw this mad rush from
many other countries,
I think somebody even
described it as its own virus,
to try to come up with new technologies,
particularly around what
I guess we'll describe
as contact tracing apps.
The same was true in Canada.
As we looked at what was
taking place elsewhere,
we had many of our political leaders
and others that started entertaining
some of these possibilities.
It was, I think, a fair amount
of that was taking place
below the radar screen in Canada.
So we didn't have any
formal announcements,
at least we didn't have anything
formally announced very quickly,
but we did have a whole series
of different initiatives,
or we had sometimes some of
the scientists in the AI field
and the tech field groups
from Shopify, for example,
working on different potential solutions.
We had privacy commissioners
sort of pop up and say,
"We wanna ensure that you're considering
some of these kinds of issues."
We had law and policy people
who are also expressing
some of their views
and potential concerns
around some of these issues,
and we get the CIFAR group
that you just mentioned.
So there was a lot of that kind of work.
Where we've moved, I think,
over the last couple of months
is that at the provincial level,
we had our first, I think,
more full scale experimentation
with one of these apps in Alberta,
the ABTraceTogether app,
which went live in early May,
so it's been around for
a couple of months now.
There's also been a full
review that was conducted
by the Alberta Information
and Privacy Commissioner,
Jill Clayton.
You mentioned my podcast,
and Commissioner Clayton appeared on it,
and I thought provided some
really interesting insights,
both into some of the positive benefits
that she saw with the app as
well as how it was rolled out,
but also some of the lingering concerns.
For the rest of the country
at a national level,
there is still, I think,
perhaps to some surprise,
a little bit of uncertainty
about what precisely we're going to get.
I mean, the latest announcement
is that the federal government
is coming forward with an app.
It is using some of the work
that was done through some
people at Shopify and others,
and Ontario will be the first
testing ground for this.
This was supposed to have
launched several weeks ago.
It still has not launched.
The Canadian Digital
Service has a beta test
that is ongoing right now,
and it's closed for new new participants,
but they are at least testing something.
And I think as recently as just yesterday,
The Logic reported that there
were several other provinces
that are anxious to become
involved in the federal app.
So there is some amount
of momentum for an app
that the reality is virtually no Canadians
have had the chance to use yet,
it is late in terms of
being made available,
and I think there are
some lingering doubts
about effectiveness of apps
given the experience that
we've seen elsewhere.
We are a little bit in a late
mover advantage situation
where many others have
moved faster than we have.
We can, I think, learn from
some of those experiences,
and one of the things that we've learned
is that perhaps the
enormous emphasis on apps
that we saw back in March
was somewhat misplaced.
- Great. Thank you.
And I wanna come back on
a number of those points,
but particularly on privacy,
so let's talk about that
when we move forward.
Carly, I have to admit,
I've sort of lost the thread
in terms of what is happening
in the U.K. with your app,
so I'm really looking
forward to hearing from you
in terms of where things stand.
- It's like we're in the seventh season
of "Lost" or something when it
comes to the app in the U.K.,
so you're forgiven
for not having fully the
plot twists and turns.
I mean, lots of
similarities with the U.K.,
sorry, with Canada, but,
of course, from the outset,
some very different kind
of fundamental differences
between the two jurisdictions key,
essential to which is the
kind of centralized nature
of the health system in the U.K.
and the absence of a federal system,
which means, from the start,
this has been a national initiative.
And it's also useful to
know that in recent years
there's been a new body set up called NHSX
in the SpaceX tradition,
which, you'll be unsurprised to know,
has remit for developing new technologies
around the health system.
So the contact tracing app
that started being debated
internally in mid-March
came out of NHSX and was very much led
by computer scientists
who are either in the
organization or affiliated with it
through the National Center
for Data Science and AI,
which is called the Alan Turing Institute,
and that's where lots of the early
kind of drive behind
the contact tracing app
in the U.K. came from, but, of course,
was responding to this kind
of international movement
or building momentum in favor
of contact tracing apps,
which I think specifically came
out of Singapore originally.
So in the U.K., the plot twists and turns
have included a big shift
in government rhetoric
from talking about the
app has been central
to the pandemic response,
to over time there being
slightly muted government statements
or claims around the app.
So the explicit language changed from,
"This is no longer the cake itself;
it's the cherry on top of the cake,"
and, "This is not kind of
central to our strategy."
And that really followed
as testing was undertaken.
There was a testing of the
app on the Isle of Wight,
which is a kind of
relatively closed community
of about 150,000 Britains.
And as information came out
about challenges that
the testing was facing,
the kind of government rhetoric
was scaled down quite a lot.
But the other big debate
in the U.K. context
has been the way the NHS decided
to technically architect
the app originally,
was to build a bespoke system
that was about centralizing
the data collected
through the app in the hands of the NHS
so that the NHS could run its
own risk scoring algorithms
off the data collected around proximity,
exposure, and notification,
and alert people according
to up-to-date evidence
about their understanding of
particular local outbreaks.
So they chose to have this
more centralized system,
which required more disclosure
of data from individuals
and differed considerably from
the decentralized approach
that Google and Apple decided to develop,
building on the work of quite a number
of researchers across Europe.
And that became quite
a contentious decision
on the part of the NHS, that
they chose a centralized
rather than a decentralized system.
Now there was certainly some arguments
in favor of a centralized system,
including that it would
enable more information
to go into the hands of
public health authorities,
but there were a number
of technical difficulties
in rolling out the centralized system
that the NHS developed, not least of which
is that it simply didn't
really work on iPhones
because of the functionality
of Bluetooth needing to
overcome the iOS requirements.
So in the end, the NHS has been forced
into a corner around that
and has reverted to using
the Google/Apple API,
so the decentralized approach.
The Isle of Wight tests,
which was based on the
centralized version,
has kind of gone into
the annals of history.
We're now heading into phase two,
developing a decentralized app.
Testing is apparently about to start.
And I think we're,
as Michael put a quite nice spinner on it,
about having a late mover advantage,
I think that definitely
applies to the U.K.
It doesn't seem like they're in any rush
to roll out the app now.
I think it's probably fair
that they've been a little bit burned
by the first experience,
and there are some questions, I think,
still around the efficacy of the app.
I think they are still convinced
that it's going to be
a useful tool for them,
but perhaps the emphasis
is more on using it
as a way to order and return test results
than necessarily only around
exposure notification,
so it's kind of expanding its remit,
I suppose, at the moment.
- Hmm, well, that's very interesting.
Thanks. Thanks very much.
Okay, so I'm gonna now, I wanna
shift and ask you, Michael,
a little bit more about privacy,
but I wanna do it within
this context of public trust
because we talked a lot about
the importance of public trust
and both in terms of
adoption of the technology
but then sustaining and monitoring
the technology moving forward.
Talked a lot about that
in our report, Michael,
but, Carly, we picked up on
that a lot out of your report,
"Exit Through the App Store,"
which you had released probably
about two or three weeks before we did.
So that was a very useful...
So framing it within the
public trust context,
Michael, can you talk a little bit more
about your conversation with the
Alberta Information and Privacy
Commissioner around privacy,
the privacy impact
assessment that she's done,
where you think some of
the remaining concerns
are from a privacy perspective with now?
- Sure, so, I mean,
so I'm happy to talk a bit about Alberta
'cause I think there's
some interesting things
that come out of that,
but I think more broadly
on a national level,
and I'll come back to Alberta in a moment,
I think we're paying in
Canada a bit of a price
for having not addressed
some of the privacy
and data governance frameworks
that I think many have been
calling for an updating
for many, many years now
when it comes to this kind of issue,
because on the assumption
that implementing
and using this app is
going to be voluntary,
we're not a country, I think,
where we would have a mandated requirement
to install this app.
Then you've gotta be able
to convince the public
both that it, I think, provides some good,
but also that it doesn't do any harm
and that you can trust both
those that have created the app,
those that may have access to the app,
as well as all the various broader privacy
and data implications.
And so trust really is
at the core, I think,
of getting the kinds of
adoption levels that you need
in order to have this app reach
any kind of effectiveness.
And I think what we've
seen in many countries,
that it is very difficult
to get to that point.
And then we see it more
broadly in society right now,
people distrusting everything
from vaccines to the
information they get on COVID,
so are they really going to
entrust installing an app
that by design tracks where
they are or where they've been
as well as who they may
have come into contact with.
So it's a pretty high bar to reach,
and I think in Canada
we haven't established
the kinds of privacy frameworks,
or at least updated our privacy
and governance frameworks,
to be able, I think, to convince people
to pay attention to those kinds of issues,
that we've got kind of the
regulatory wrapping around this,
that they should be able to trust this.
That's not to say that
many won't, I think,
install these programs anyway.
There's a great deal of
concern, and many will say
that whatever some of
my privacy concerns are,
my health related
concerns are even greater,
and if this app will help,
and if they can be convinced
that an app like this will help,
I think many will say it's worth the risk.
But I don't think that's a choice
that people really should have to make.
I mean, I think that these
are the kinds of issues
that we should have been
addressing up until now
and still should be addressing,
and it is successive governments.
It's not really a political issue
of liberal or conservative.
I think it's successive
governments that have,
in many ways, really failed
us to address these issues,
such that when you start peeling
back the onion a little bit
and trying to identify,
well, what law applies?
What protections do I have?
What are the penalties for misuse?
It can be challenging to even get
the kinds of answers
you're looking for at times
because health is largely
at the provincial level,
these are federal apps
that may be implemented
at a provincial level,
privacy is shared to a certain extent,
and it depends a little bit whether or not
it's the private sector
that's gaining access
or the government itself.
So there are a lot of
those kinds of challenges.
I'll note a couple of things
specific to the Alberta app,
which are things that we
oughta be thinking about,
and the privacy commissioner there found
that they hadn't thought enough about,
and those have to do in a
sense with exiting the app.
Is this a "Hotel California" type of app
where you can check in, but never leave?
And I think there are on...
There have been concerns.
People have raised this really
from the very beginning.
How do you ensure that once, we hope,
this pandemic finally comes to an end,
both how do I exit using the app,
and how do we ensure that this app,
the apps become decommissioned
such that the surveillance elements
that are really baked into these apps
aren't a legacy of COVID?
I thought that when the
privacy commissioner in Alberta
talked a bit about this,
it became clear that there
weren't good answers.
In fact, on the technical side,
with the ability to delete
or stop using the app,
there were challenges,
and so you had to pay
really close attention
to be able to stop using
the app altogether.
She found that the health
authority in Alberta
hadn't really spent much
time thinking about,
"When does this end?" and "How
do we decommission the app?"
And while, I mean,
at a certain level, that's understandable.
People are running a thousand
miles an hour, it feels like,
to try to deal with so many
different issues all at once.
I think many in the
privacy/civil liberties community
identified this as one
of the core concerns,
that we could not allow
surveillance style apps,
no matter how valuable they might be,
and, as we've talked about,
the jury's still out on that.
But even assuming that they are valuable
given the current circumstance,
we couldn't allow it to be the new normal,
and we had to bake in those
kinds of considerations
about decommissioning the
app from the very outset.
And at least in the Alberta experience,
it's pretty clear that that didn't happen,
and we don't know enough
yet at the federal level,
but one would hope that at least
they've learned that lesson
in providing real clarity
about what happens,
not just in terms of getting
people to use the app
but stopping use of the app as well.
- Mm-hmm. Great.
So in this question of public trust,
which is informed by
privacy, as Michael says,
but also in terms of the terms of use
and around the app itself,
Carly, the Ada Lovelace Institute has done
some really interesting
work on public deliberation
and consultation around technologies,
particularly in response to COVID.
I love the name of the report.
It's titled "It's
Complicated." (chuckling)
Which it is.
Can you talk a little bit...
I think that would be a really
useful lesson in Canada,
for us to get some sense
of how you did that,
where you thought the concerns were
both in terms of privacy
but, more broadly,
in terms of efficacy
and other areas as well,
and where you see that work going
in terms of informing
your work moving forward.
- Yeah, so an organization,
we use public deliberation
methodologies quite a lot,
and by that I mean essentially
long-form public focus groups,
which are also often called mini publics
or citizen juries and citizen assemblies.
I'm not sure how much this is part
of the policy discussion in Canada,
but it's become a very popular thing
to think about recently,
and I think some of that responds
to kind of political realities
around these intractable issues,
such as, for example, Brexit.
There's this notion that you can start
to bring together very disparate
views on complicated issues
through this type of
long-form public engagement.
We've been doing one prior to the crisis
on the use of facial recognition
and other types of biometrics
technologies in the U.K.,
but during the crisis,
we convened one of the
first online citizen juries
or citizen deliberation initiatives
over quite a rapid period.
So we did it, normally these
can go for weeks or months,
we did it over three weeks
with 30 members of the public.
And essentially what we do is we turn them
into kind of lay experts
on a particular issue.
We bring together a range
of different experts
and help them present
evidence to the citizens,
and then the citizens
deliberate on certain questions.
In this case, what would it
take to build public confidence
and trust in a contact tracing app
and other types of
technologies around COVID?
And it was a very interesting
and illustrative experience.
I should say it happened against
the backdrop of two events.
One was the killing of George Floyd
and the momentum around
Black Lives Matter,
which certainly has had
an impact in the U.K.
and came at the same time
as a very important report
which showed that people from black
and minority ethnic
backgrounds are twice as likely
to die of COVID in the
U.K. than white people.
So the question of inequalities
and structural racism very
much rising up the agenda
during the period of this deliberation.
And the other was a
slightly nonsensical event
in which a key advisor
to the prime minister
was found to be breaking lockdown rules
by driving to a castle
in the North of England.
That was a very English example,
involving a castle, of course.
And that raised these big
questions around public trust,
and does the government expect
us to continue to comply
with these quite onerous lockdown rules?
So we saw, interestingly,
how those impacted the
public's feeling around trust
in government-based technologies.
But broadly speaking,
we found that, actually,
privacy and data protection
weren't at the top
of people's lists in terms
of concerns around this app,
though they certainly
are there in terms of
that building block that's
required to build public trust.
But first and foremost was that the public
wanted to see a transparent evidence base
around why this technology should be used,
and they felt that that should
be shared transparently,
and they were suspicious
when any information was
kept from the public.
So the Isle of Wight trial
that I mentioned earlier,
there wasn't very much
transparency around that
other than that it was happening,
and the public felt
that that was something
that undermined their trust.
There was also a lot of
emphasis from the citizens
on independent assessment
and review of the technology.
So they wanted to see
independent ethics boards
and independent oversight mechanisms,
independent experts weighing in
on whether the choices being
made were the right ones,
and they wanted to know it had been tested
by independent experts.
The third element was around
clarity on the use of data.
To Michael's point,
they wanted to know when
their data would be deleted,
when would this app be stopped being used,
and so there we found kind of support
for the notion of sunset
clauses, for example,
or hard stops on some of this technology.
And then, finally, they were very aware
that we needed to consider
the system as a whole.
So they were unwilling
to consider these trust
around the particular technology
as separate from trust in the government
and trust in the system
deploying the technology,
and that's where the questions
about this special advisor
breaking lockdown rules
came up a lot.
So it wasn't only do you trust
how you're using the app,
it's but what about these
political figures around the app,
and do you trust the system
in which it's being embedded.
And so I think those kind
of findings lend themselves,
and we're working on
something now, lend themselves
to how to do it properly
next time type checklist
because I think there are
some really concrete things
that come out from that
in terms of what the government can do
to kind of be more transparent,
to institute independent mechanisms,
to make it clear when
there are sunset clauses
and when data will stop
being used, et cetera,
that can actually increase public trust,
that are separate to but
on top of data protection
and privacy protections as well.
- Great, so I think those
are all the questions, right?
That have been swirling in
Canada as well around the apps
and sort of trying to
get some understanding.
So I think that's really
important for us to learn
from the process that you put into place.
And I wanted to come back
on one particular item
you mentioned, Michael,
and talk a little bit to you
about this notion of
independent oversight,
this capacity for evaluation and auditing
by an independent body who is that...
We talked a little bit
about it in the report.
I've heard there should be a commissioner
of sort of COVID contact tracing apps,
in some jurisdictions are known,
but what do you think is the right way
to establish that independence
within all of the structures
that are already in place in Canada?
But is there more needed?
- That's a great question.
I mean, while there are some
who have proposed specific commissioners,
and I think that the experience in Canada
and the prevailing view would be
that the same kind of
independent oversight
that Carly just mentioned
would be essential here too,
my own view, when you're
moving as quickly as you are,
if you can rely on an existing
structure that is trusted,
so much the better.
And so if I look at the
experience in Alberta
where they had, I think, really,
some really strong technical chops
in terms of being able to look
a little bit under the hood at the app,
and then take that and
link it to underlying
or the governance framework
and the legal framework
to see where there were potential issues.
I believe that our federal
Privacy Commissioner
would have many of the
same kinds of skillsets
and same kind of tools within the office.
It seems to me...
You mentioned Mona Nemer,
the chief science advisor.
I think the government
has some of those people.
I think the Privacy Commissioner operating
as an independent agent
is probably best suited
to be able to deal with
some of these issues,
but I do think right now in Canada,
we're in a bit of a dangerous spot.
I mean, we, for months, as
many Canadians will know,
had the prime minister come up
with a daily press conference,
which may have confused a
little bit regular face time
and press conferences
with actual transparency
about what's taking place.
So there were a lot of announcements.
I think there's less insight
into what was really taking place
or how some of the
decisions were being made.
I think, frankly, we're
seeing that being played out
literally today with some of
the investigations into WE
and concerns around
that particular program.
And while there was this desire
to address many issues
all at the same time,
which creates its own set of challenges,
that really only enhances
the need for transparency
about why decisions are being made,
establishing protocols that
ensure that science advisors
and other experts are able to chime in
and have an impact on what the
underlying policy looks like,
and then ensuring that once
those things are rolled out,
that you've got the
independent oversight built in.
I'm not sure that we're, I'm
not convinced at this stage
that we've done that all
that well, to be candid.
We've put together these various reports.
It's a little bit of a black box.
I don't know that we know
to a significant extent
precisely how that
information has been used.
And I'm not also sure
that we have established,
as we are on the very cusp
of trying to roll this out,
I'm not sure that we even know necessarily
what oversight mechanisms will be built
into the process either.
So I think there are
some lingering concerns
with respect to some of that oversight,
and I guess I would conclude,
the response to your question,
by saying that if we take the position
that we need to create
something from scratch
to address this issue, I
think that runs the risk
of creating an even greater disconnect
between having something launch
and having the kind of
oversight that you need in place
ideally from day one
or even before day one
because you want to ensure
that that oversight has played a role
throughout the development
process as well.
- Great. Carly, I wanted to...
We've been talking a
little bit about trust
and trust in the
government-produced technology,
but clearly these are
public-private partnerships as well.
So in Canada with COVID Alert,
it will be Shopify and Blackberry,
and then the Google and Apple API as well.
That will be part of it.
So what do you think are the extra steps
that policymakers need to ensure are taken
so that the public understands
and can evaluate whether
it's the procurement
or the roles of private
sector developers or firms
that may participate in
a government technology?
- Yeah, that's a great question.
I mean, in the U.K.,
that hasn't been as relevant
for the contact tracing app
because it's been so
firmly within the hands
of the NHS from the start, although,
I will say that in the public
deliberation work we did,
there was great concern around
the potential sale of data
to corporate entities.
That was something that
people wanted to see
would be protected from the outset.
I think that echoes what other
things we know, pre-COVID,
about public trust in the U.K.,
in different institutions.
So the NHS enjoys, by far and away,
the most amount of public trust
out of any British institution,
and I would say, broadly speaking,
there's greater trust in government
than there is in companies in the U.K.
But in terms of government procurement
of tech system, more broadly,
or partnerships around
technology providers,
there has been another
initiative launched during COVID,
which was the establishment
of what's called a data store,
which is a kind of high
level data analytics platform
which brings together lots
of disparate data sources
within the NHS to try to keep
track of resource allocation,
what beds are free in which hospitals
around the country, et cetera.
And that project was
launched with Microsoft,
Palantir, and a small AI
company called Faculty AI.
There's been quite a lot of
concern raised about that
by privacy/civil liberties activists,
or advocates, sorry, and
others kind of scrutinizing
the information government
system, governance system,
primarily because Palantir
was awarded the contract
with a fee of one pound,
and then the contract was
renewed for a million pounds.
There was obviously concerns
there about transparency,
procurement processes, but
also Palantir's history
as being a defense contractor
and the kind of ethical considerations,
which are very real and substantial,
of the British health system contracting
with an American company
that has that background.
I think that that has raised more eyebrows
and raised some big questions
about what it looks like
to procure technology,
in particular in the health system.
We've done some other citizen juries work
around health data
partnerships looking at...
There has been some quite prominent
health data partnerships
in the UK recently
between companies like DeepMind and Google
and health and hospitals within the UK,
and a big finding that
was that in terms of
what people consider to be fair,
transparency is incredibly important.
So they wanna see contracts
in the public domain,
they wanna see open procurement processes,
but also they want to see
equitable distribution
of benefits from those
partnerships, and, in particular,
and I'm not sure if this
is a U.K. specific issue,
but I suspect that there are
similar questions in Canada.
There are geographical
inequalities in the U.K.
between the North and the
South in terms of deprivation
and affluence and opportunity and jobs,
and the idea that health data partnerships
or technology partnerships with NHS trusts
in different parts of the country
might benefit some people more than others
was a cause for concern.
So this notion that you need to have
kind of a fair playing
field across the country
and that everybody should benefit equally
was an interesting finding
from that, and, I suspect,
applies to other types of
technology development,
whether it be in health system
or other forms of government
use of technology.
- Thank you, so now I'm starting
to get some questions from the audience.
I have two questions, and they're similar
because they both speak to
sort of the efficacy of an app,
one in terms of the sort of the level
of public adoption required,
but also in terms of its
integration or non-integration
within a health system's
data setting and otherwise.
Would either of you like to speak
to either of those points
in terms of some of the
considerations that we both,
both Canada and the U.K.,
need to be thinking about
in terms of the deployment of apps
and their actual efficacy and
uptake within the population?
And maybe potentially, Michael,
also in terms of mobility in Canada,
across provinces and otherwise
in terms of the population.
Do you wanna take a stab at that, Michael?
- Sure, I can start with
just a couple of comments.
I think studies have
indicated 60% or higher
as sort of the number
that people often cite.
I don't know that we've seen many,
if any countries, achieve that level,
so it raises the question
of how effective some of these are.
Part of it, I guess, depends,
to come back to your intro,
where we're using contact tracing apps
sort of as a broad term
to cover a number of
different kinds of apps,
and so in terms of the
linkage to health information,
in some instances, these apps
aren't necessarily designed
to do that at all.
I mean, and so one of the
ways that there is a hope
to try to foster and gender
greater trust within the public
is to say the government
will not have access
to this information,
this will be information
that you will have,
and so you will be able
to be notified effectively through the app
as to whether or not you've
had exposure to someone.
And so you may wanna get a test
or self-quarantine and the like,
but that's not necessarily one
that links directly into government data,
where there might be trends
or other sort of information
about those that have this much less apps
that we've seen in some countries
that have been designed to
try to enforce quarantine,
about trying to literally track
where people are going and the like.
So there are a lot of
different uses that we've seen.
I think Carly mentioned
some other potential uses
that people are starting to
think about for those apps,
and one would think even now,
as we struggle with the issue
of trying to get our kids
back to school in just over
a month, people will say,
"Well, isn't there some role
that these apps can play in that regard?
Longterm-care facilities, of course,
have been one of the biggest
sources of problems in Canada.
Isn't there something
technology can do there?"
So I think we see the prospect
of these apps morphing
into some of the kinds of contact tracing
that depends on fairly
high adoption rates,
potentially into some other uses
that are perhaps not quite so
dependent on those numbers.
Quickly on the issue of provincial issues,
this creates some real thorny challenges
from a Canadian perspective.
And so you mentioned the Alberta app,
and we've got an Ontario app.
I live in Ottawa.
And, quite literally, from
my office at the university,
you can see into Quebec.
I mean, it's just several
blocks away, in effect,
to go to the bridge and go into Quebec.
And so the idea that you'd have an app
that works on one side of the river
but not on the other side of the river,
it doesn't make a ton of sense
given that there are many people
who commute each day back and forth
between the provinces
for work and otherwise,
at times where we're not seemingly
mainly working from home.
And so how effective is
an app where it stops
at a provincial border?
Not really in terms of the way people
often live their lives today,
much less the desire to ensure
that Canadians can freely move
in and around the country,
especially at a time
when international borders
raise some real issues.
So how we overcome
what is areas traditionally
of provincial competence
with national standards or a national app
is an issue that we're
still grappling with.
You see that the...
I guess the current approach
is what we're seeing,
which is let's try it out in a province,
or perhaps two or three,
and hope that it is
sufficiently effective,
that everybody jumps on board,
a sort of network effect
when it comes to some of these apps.
Becomes in everybody's interest
to adopt roughly the same approach,
and you get some of that
interoperability of data.
- Great. Carly, thoughts on that?
- Yeah, I just wanted to
share a resource, actually,
which I'm gonna put in the chat,
and I think attendees can access it,
but it links to a spreadsheet
that we've been keeping updated,
which tracks what we
know about the deployment
of contact tracing apps
in various countries
around the world.
I think we've got about 50
different countries there.
And it goes to...
The information in there goes to some
of the questions raised here,
so including around which countries
are using verified test
data or diagnostic data
versus which countries are
using self-reported data,
which I do think is an is
an important distinction
that has implications
for how effective the app's going to be.
And the other one is the level of uptake
or penetration in
countries around the world.
I think Michael said earlier,
we haven't seen very high
levels of uptake in any country,
certainly not higher
than 40% in any country.
And those countries that
have had at the higher end,
such as Australia, Iceland, and Singapore,
have not reported any significant benefit
from the contact tracing app itself,
but rather have said it needs to form part
of a manual contact tracing system.
I think that even though,
I mean, most studies that
have been done in the U.K.
in terms of what people say they will do,
in terms of using the app,
show that about 75% of people
say they will use an app,
but, in effect,
we know that that probably
doesn't play out, actually.
So the Isle of Wight
example being around 40%.
Again, that seems to be where
it tops out around the world.
But I think there is a,
in terms of the efficacy,
there's a big unknown still,
which is what do people actually do
when they get a notification
from an app saying,
"You need to stay home now for 14 days
because you've been in
contact with someone"?
I think that that behavioral question,
it depends on so many factors,
including their trust in the app,
including whether they think
they were wearing a mask
at a time that they were
in touch with someone,
and therefore the app is wrong,
whether they think other
people are gaming the app,
but also can they afford to stay home
from their job for two weeks?
Does their employer have
some type of provision
for compliance with social isolation,
managers, et cetera, et cetera.
So those types of efficacy
behavior questions
just haven't been answered
yet, and we don't yet know
from international comparative experience
how that's playing out.
- Great. So we have
about five minutes left.
So I wanna make sure that
I just pause for a moment,
and, Michael and Carly, and just ask you,
we've touched on a number
of different potential policy areas,
whether it's privacy
framework, restricted use
in terms of the data and
the technology itself,
questions of equity and inclusion.
Carly, public engagement and transparency,
harmonization and mobility efficacy.
Are there, I wanna make sure,
are there any other really
important policy issues
that you think maybe are not as well known
or not as focused on today
that we need to be thinking about
as we take this question forward?
And you each have about two minutes
to respond to that, so I apologize.
Carly, I'll ask you first.
- (chuckles) well, I suppose there is...
For me, there's a longer
standing question,
which is what does technology development
in government look like going forward,
and what's the best practice, actually,
for how government should develop
and use technology as part
of their policymaking?
And I think that the experience
of the contact tracing app,
in the UK at least, I think
it will be studied for years
from a kind of statecraft
and policymaking perspective
because it was, in some respects,
just such a blunder in
kind of many facets,
but also brought out all
these interesting questions
about how does the ideal
or the hype around technology
drive policymaking?
How does it determine the
strategic choices we make?
And what comes first, the chicken or egg,
the policy or the technology,
and what is the relationship
between the two of those?
But also, and this is a
particular interest for me,
being someone who works
on ethics and data,
what is the role of ethics
boards, ethic advisory councils,
in feeding into or
overseeing the development
of a government technology,
in particular when those ethics boards
don't have any teeth
to stop the deployment
or ask fundamental questions about it,
when they can really
only tinker at the edges.
So I think that so many governments
and companies are now paying
lip service to ethics,
but what does it mean
to put it into practice
in the context of policymaking at pace
and technology development at pace?
And I think then the
other just kind of issue
we haven't spoken about,
but it's worth referencing,
is how do we deal with digital exclusion
in the context of policy
that relies on technology,
in particular in the health sector?
So in the U.K. around 20% of
people don't use smartphones.
If a policy is specifically dependent
on the use of the smartphone,
how is that going to
exacerbate health inequalities
and health outcomes for the most excluded,
and how do we overcome that?
- Fabulous, thank you. Michael.
- (chuckles) That was
a great answer, Carly.
I guess I would choose
to focus on the issue
of how do you move from expertise
within the broader public
and ensure that it's somehow becomes part
of your policy development.
In other words, how do you
do good science policy?
In Canada, we had a government for that
for the last number of years,
(indistinct) was elected really,
put a great deal of emphasis
on consultation, right?
Sometimes we felt that it was
almost too much consultation,
that almost every decision
had to be widely consulted.
You have to have a lot of hearings.
You had to then tell
people what they heard
and then perhaps consult
on what they had said,
and sometimes there was this frustration
that we were never moving
beyond consultation
into actual policy development.
In this instance, there was no luxury
to engage in some of that kind of broad,
well, what do you think?
You've got 90 days to let us know.
And I think it's, in certain respects,
we have found ourselves wanting,
in terms of trying to be able
to find an effective
policy development process,
obviously, at a moment of crisis,
but at a time when there
is the expertise out there
in the community, a deep desire
to become actively engaged.
It was very clear how many
people were just running
to say, "Here, let me help."
And I don't know that
government had a good way
to be able to take that and process it
in an open and transparent way
such that we would get better outcomes.
Instead, there was a
little bit of who you knew
is who they would
traditionally be talking to.
There was a lot of talking
up without a lot of clarity
as to whether or not it
was being heard at all.
And as we've said, we
still don't even know
what the outcomes are
necessarily going to be.
And so I think we have
to, coming out of this,
recognize this won't the last time
we face emergency situations
and wanna try to tap into expertise,
and we've gotta be able to
develop better mechanisms
to establish good policy that
don't involve two, three,
four year cycles for how that takes place,
but rather allow us to move much faster
in the way that we would say,
some in the private sector and others say,
they've gotta be able to
react and move quickly.
Government has to be
able to do that as well.
- I think that's a
perfect note to end it on,
sort of where we started.
That is the work.
That is our work to do,
I think, moving forward.
The two of you have been in
leaders in showing new ways
in which experts can, and the public can,
speak and inform policy moving forward.
So thank you both very much.
I think there were well over 15 questions
that I didn't even get
to from the audience,
so I apologize to all of the
people who had good questions.
Obviously, there's more
here for us to discuss,
but I really feel like
we have supercharged
the discussion today
with Carly and Michael,
so thanks so much.
I also just wanna take a minute
to thank Fiona Cunningham,
Jackie Sullivan, and Wendy Hall.
They're the ones who made
it all happen here at CIFAR,
and to encourage you all
to visit our website,
cifar.ca, to download the
report we talked about,
to visit the Ada Lovelace
Institute website
in the U.K. as well for
many of the good resources
that Carly spoke about as well.
You can find out at our website
more about this particular series,
but also to pick up on
that recording of the talk
if it's useful moving forward.
Thank you all again.
Thank you, Michael. Thank you, Carly.
- Thank you.
- Be well, everyone,
and we'll talk soon.